it was billed as a historic day for
European democracy as jean-claude
juncker the chosen one made his final
speech to mep s before a secret ballot
to officially anoint him as president of
the Commission this is more or less a
historical dimension of this day to show
to the people that say could decide who
is leading Europe in the future and that
is that this really a great step for
more democracy on European level the
mood inside the chamber was cordial with
lots of handshakes even for those not so
willing to offer their hand mr. young he
made a speech that appealed to right and
left promising to rien dust relies
Europe and to get the 25 million
unemployed back in work this was part of
what he called a European dream but a
dream that included an understanding of
the dynamics of the community new salon
des actor coming out there blow up
Mitsuko sweeper kontol edita knee
contadina soon he also detailed plans
for a European digital market and
greater energy security but possibly his
biggest pledge a 300 billion euro
injection for growth and investment
before getting here mr. Younker already
had the support or the Liberals and
socialists but his speech had also gone
down well with others really short that
he understands the true challenges he
understands that something has to change
and he also outlined in which direction
he would like to go he is not only
talking about more Europe but he's
talking about democracy versus troika
the one group not giving their support
for the Conservatives it seemed to me to
be a typical speech that was trying to
appeal to as many people as possible and
as many agendas as possible that's a bit
risky really I'm ep's made their way
back to the chamber to hear the result
it was no surprise mr. Younker was
elected with a majority of 422 votes
support coming from the European
People's Party liberals socialists and
some greens but for all those MEP he's
happy to the back of mr. Barroso well
he's not going anywhere until the new
commission is elected